well it's time to get into the
valentine's day spirit and love
obviously
is in the air and rocky theas has got
you covered
this week yeah today she took a trip to
the twilight zone to show us
how we can celebrate with a sci-fi twist
if that's what you're into
yeah if you're into that kind of thing
obviously the kids are loving it this
you can have a perfect play date or
birthday party here but monster mini
golf is not just for the kids
no it's for adults too it's a perfect
date night because we're kicking off
valentine's week so this is the founder
of monster mini golf let's talk about
what people can do here for date night
yeah we're actually really talking let's
take a look we're actually a really cool
date night spot um we're 18 holes in
mini golf and it can kind of keep you
talking if you're really shy yeah if
you're really competitive it's even cool
for that
look at that yeah it's very visually
stimulating
trivia on the golf course we do contests
and things like that we have music on
the golf course so we keep it lots of
fun
that's awesome and i understand you've
had proposals here you've had first
dates yeah yeah we do we have a lot of a
lot of first dates obviously
but we've and we've actually had people
come back from their first date and do
um a proposal here as well and we've
even taken a step further than that
oh my god okay wait before you get to
the step further i feel like
you know in the spirit of valentine's
day it all starts with the right pickup
line right
yeah i guess and in sci-fi world you got
to have the right
pickup line with the sci-fi theme so
because i'm so smooth
i've written a few downs all right on my
paper here all right so i'm going to
start i'm going to start off okay you
mind no go ahead go
ahead christina you are out of this
world
would you like to boldly go where no one
has gone before oh
okay and this one is from my editor
david this one's from my editor david
you're gonna like this
you're like a phaser on stunning oh jeez
are you flushing under that mask i think
she's blushing under that mask
so after the pickup line after the
sci-fi date night here
we get a sci-fi wedding right we do
sci-fi wedding chapel it's awesome
show us boys show us the way i think we
might have something cool going on
something cool like an actual wedding we
do gosh we have to be quiet obviously
because
so as a bride coming in here what do i
get
you get pretty much whatever you
intergalactically want
we will do anything it's just a fun
really cool
sci-fi wedding chapel so sci-fi um
vip passes we've got custom takes any
minister you could possibly want
wow yeah that's awesome and of course
you guys have some other
venues around town as well right that
have different themes we do we have a
kiss venue over at the rio
and so we have a rock and roll chapel
there as well love that yes
full-on rock and roll so we kind of got
both sides of the spectrum going on
you've got it covered for everyone
you've never done
monster mini golf so last question here
um what makes the perfect
vegas wedding imagination and love
that's great thank you christina oh
thank you for this fine establishment
i will should we do the should we do oh
okay
i'm not very good at this greetings
salutations bye